Django Unchained is with my most
anticipated movies of the rest of the
year and I haven't really talked about
it too much on my channel I just wanted
to wait till this moment when I saw the
first trailer so I could really give you
like my full opinion of how I feel about
the movie I feel about Quentin Tarantino
in general of course how I feel about
the trailer I love Tarantino he's one of
my favorite directors writers everything
I movie czar fantastic I mean they're so
well-written and with such great depth
and just so entertaining I mean he's
able to take situations that seem really
intense dark and disturbing and somehow
find some wit and charm to them he's so
good at that and with this trailer I'm
seeing that same talent again this is
the story of a slave played by Jamie
Foxx who's freed by Christoph Waltz and
then sent to this plantation where
Leonardo DiCaprio is like rolling over
all these slaves and everything and
apparently Jamie Foxx's wife is enslaved
there by him thus Django is Unchained
and he set loose upon these people to
get a little bit of revenge now of
course I love the way this movie looks
we've got Quentin Tarantino's like
signature zoom in extremely fast on
something shot that be sure there's a
name for that crash zoom is that what
it's called note to self
no director terms to sound clever and
smarter than you actually are DiCaprio
looks great too and you can tell that
he's really relishing the evilness of
this villainous character he's funny you
know he's got wit to him he's got charm
it's like Christoph Waltz an inglorious
basterds you feel like he is terrible he
could kill you possibly at any moment he
does horrible things yeah
I'm a murderer I'm a slave owner I don't
care I'm awesome and that's Tarantino's
genius I said this in the beginning of
the video I'm saying again he is so good
at creating the most dire dark situation
and making it fun but at the same time
he's really good at catching those deep
and dark and emotional moments his line
this trailer I love Jamie Foxx looking
at this guy and he just goes like the
way you die boy that just sums up his
character right there I mean he's
clearly a guy out for revenge he wants
to get back at these people who enslaved
him and slaved his wife and separated
them Christoph Waltz looks fantastic as
usual he's always good I also love that
final line where he's like Django the D
silent
just in case you didn't realize that
already I love this trailer what do you
guys think of it let me know below and
until next time guys if you'd like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes